IT'S FIRED UP OVER THE SEATTLE E
PICK UP IN THE EXPANSION, THE DS
THAT SHOT.
>> Jeff: THE BLUE JACKETS WIN
THE DEFENSIVET IN, BEND
DON'T BREAK MENTALITY, TAKE A
PENALTY IN THE SCORING CHANCES.
GAVRIKOV WILL SEND IT UP BUT NOT
THE OUTCOME THE PUCK ISS TO THEF
THE COLUMBUS NET.
YOUOOD WORK.
>> Jeff:f: SHOT AND A REBOUND
BLOCKED AWAY. THE
SHOT IN THE
IT'S ROSLOVIC WITH A CENTERING
PASS, OLIVER
OLEKSIAK.
>> Jeff: HERE IS NYQUIUI. SETTL.
FIGHTS IT OFF
>> SECOND PERIOD COME HIGH ENOU.
CIRCLING PUCK, YOU CAN
SESE NICE START, THIS
THIRD PERIOD
HE IS PROBABLY THINKING S S
>> Jody: HE'S OUT EBERLE WITH
AN ATTEMPT, THE JACKETS BLOCK BH
WERENSKI, WE'LL SEE HIM SNAP
>> Jeff: FROM THE F